المباراه التي تجمع الان امريكا وايران في
هذه الاثناء فهي الساخنه السياسيا وحتى ان
المصافحه التقليديه بين اللاعبين باتت
حدثا اهتم العالم بمتابعته في كاس العالم
عام 1998 التقطت الولايات المتحده وايران
وقام ان ذلك اللاعبون الايرانيون بنزع
فتيل القلق الجيو سياسي من خلال تسليم
الورود البيضاء للاعبين الامريكيين قبل
المباراه لكن المباراه اليوم تاتي في ظروف
مختلفه حيث الوضع الداخلي في ايران مشحون
بشكل كبير اذ- ترزح البلاد تحت واطئه
عقوبه الامريكيه قاسيه منذ عقود صحيفه
اشارت الى ان اللعبه اصبحت خطا امامنيا
اخر في الصراع بين الخصمين الجي او
سياسيين اما صحيفه واشنطن فنقلت عن اليكس
لالاس المدافع في المنتخب الامريكي قوله
ان منتخبهم ناضج بما فيه الكفايه وذو خبره
الكافيه لمعرفه ان هذا لا علاقه له
بالحكومه او السياسه
صحيفه وصف الجورنال لا كشفت ان كل نتيجه
مباراه تحمل شحنه اضافيه من التفسير
الاكبر حيث النتيجه هي اكبر من مجرد فوز
او تعادل او خساره بل انه يقع في منظور ما
يمثله لمستقبل الرياضه في الولايات
المتحده والطريقه التي ينظر بها العالم
الى الكره القدم الامريكيه